it's still pretty kind of spicy and that
is that a thing our millennial spicy is
that the flavor that we write I love I
love that I might drink a can of de
don't drink a lot of side of it when I
do it is Diet Coke Bar None in high
school I would drink diet coke every
morning at 8:00 a.m. me and my dad we
were just drinks on coke that's a cool
bonding we're diet coke then so we know
there's new flavors we just haven't got
them in our possession
yeah so these new diagnosed livers are
marketed on Millennials what do you
think are they light pink like the Lenny
ol pink you feel like I'm gonna like
them and then I'm gonna be embarrassed
that I like them I mean if they taste
good I don't care who they're marketed
towards Lacroix is like exploding
everywhere so I think it makes sense
that they want to branch out to flavored
everyone's marketing towards Millennials
I don't know why cuz we have no money at
all
what about its millennial life is it
gonna be like Instagram like that mean
let's try the new flavors jinx you owe
me a soda
nice one please okay this one smells
very strong orangie maybe it's like an
orange citrus
I in this is really hard to determine
I'm pleasantly surprised love that I
really do
he's still like taste that meat like
blood orange you case and like perfect
still Cokie that's a word it's just like
- babe maybe if they committed to the
flavor a little more it could mix well
with with vodka or like a citrusy vodka
these are need to be like mixed with
alcohol for some reason is that the
moment I'm just I'm just here to figure
out why this is for Millennials or this
just smells like bitrate dico
yeah it smells like slightly vanilla is
potentially to love the new world I
think this is the ginger one so this one
smells like ginger ale which I'm also
not mad about because it feels great
is it as mere all these spicy or am I
feel like a lime it's ginger something
it's ginger lime superb actually both
yeah it really doesn't taste like that
coke which could be a good thing people
who don't like it you're like these are
a little too light with the flavoring
but I like this combo I hundred percent
think it's going on it is ginger
supposed to be like a healthy so I I did
a detox that I couldn't shut up about
sing up wall thing talking about a wine
tasting this is definitely black cherry
I'm giving a hint of flute oh great I'm
gonna get into millennial verified on in
serious
um I get a cherry feeling that tastes
like regular diaper it's like really
really weak black cherry it's like a
miracle
yeah I think it because it just tastes
kind of normal look like a little bit of
kick at the end I was not gonna say yes
to that husband are we guessing are you
telling us way
iced tea cherry oh okay really cool if I
stand heed the moment you open this can
you take a whiff the smell is there this
tastes like a spicy cherry this looks
like a little like spritzer can I like
the branding there was Cherry Coke in
the past right I feel like we've had
Cherry Coke for a while there is Cherry
Coke this coke now I think I think oh
this has distinct something I don't know
the bad sense of smell
you know whoa oh this is strong that's
strong I want to say like melon it's
like a candy but I can't tell
ashin fruity it's like millennial
bloodhound it's mango I feel like it
tastes like a candy it's a fruit roll-up
and this would go this is wrong really
good yes I don't know where mangu became
so popular but like we made it hot I'm
just saying I'm perplexed by this one
mango I love their adjectives this
reminds me of freshman year yes I could
definitely met my number one very
millennial I was just making an
Instagram
we're not instagramming okay why would I
go he goes dad like they learn a lot
stick to the basics and then ginger lime
orange or cherry could be number two
I like the feisty cherry second yeah you
agree okay cuz I line up lock it in
final answer part of their millennial
advertising like they're like
Millennials like they've seen lemon you
know what they haven't seen like a live
twisted mango yeah do you guys feel so
millennial right now feel very
considering we just tried to arrange
them to look nice on Instagram yes I
would drink all of them I would totally
dude twisted mango with a nice classic
rock car nice maybe some lemon vodka oh
mixer this orange with a bartender but
I'm just trying to get a little bit
drunk look looks go the shadows remain
cool okay but we gotta take it in
portrait mode hey why don't you like it
down the line we actually how cool I got
it